voilà
8 mois sans C c'est quand même
catastrophique c'est quand même
scandaleux dans comme le
Sénégal l'Université de Dakar qui a plus
de 80000 étudiants 80000 étudiants
l'état du Sénégal peut veut sacrifier
pour des raisons politiques l'avenir de
étudiants
[Musique]
et la réouverture dans les meilleurs
pouron puisse sauver tout ce qu'on
demande c'est la réouverture et la
sécurisation des universités donc pour
sauver l'an académique 2022 2023 mais
les opinions politiques ne doivent pas
prévaloir sur le monde académique c'est
vrai a la liberté académique mais les
hommes politiques de tout bord ont
toujours utilisé l'université pour leur
gain politique il faudrait que ça
[Musique]
cesse non à la violence non à la
violence
[Musique]
alors les étudiants ils sont un peu
dispersés un peu
démobilisés et puis il y a certains qui
ont pris le bateau pour sortir du
Sénégal parce qu'ils pensent
effectivement que leur avenir est plus
ou moins hypothéqué voire
irrémédiablement
[Musique]
compromise